Okay well, the reason we have Scrum is...
...because I came into software development from a medical school.
I had done 11 years funded by the National Cancer Institute's research on complex adaptive systems.
And a large banking company hired me to come in and help them with their advanced technologies.
And as I looked at the way they were managing projects,...
...I realized developers were always late,...
...management was always under pressure; they were putting pressure on the developers.
The more pressure they would put on the developers, the later the project would get.
And the whole thing was designed in such a way...
...that the stable state of the system was not what you wanted.
In order to do that, we had to change the whole dynamics.
Now, what we knew from research at Bell Labs is that we had to have very few roles...
...in the team that was doing software development.
The specialized styles of activity slowed down communications and made it impossible to do.
So, one of the first things we did was we set it up;...
...we only had a team and we had a team leader.
We read a paper by two Japanese business school professors on the best teams in the world.
And they described how the best new product development teams were set up,...
...how the teams were motivated; we set up the team just like that.
The team wanted to know what we would call the team leader; we called him the scrum master.
We then, as we got the role simplified, streamlined and leaned out all the system.
We very quickly found we needed a person we called the product owner,...
...in addition to the scrum master...
...who is responsible for clearly specifying the backlog in the right ordering.
So when we ship the product, it would really take the market as a really good product.
So, we had the product owner, the Scrum master and the team.
We then turned our attention to the meetings because in order to build software fast,...
...you cannot have people going into meetings all the time where they're wasting a lot of time.
So we asked, "What of the minimal meetings we need to have for scrum?"
We knew we needed to deliver a software in short cycles, no more than four weeks.
Probably the majority of the teams now are doing two - week sprints.
So, we needed a meeting at the beginning of the sprint to define...
..."What are we going to..."
"...pull from the product backlog owned by the product owner into that two - week cycle?"
"How are we going to implement it and track it?"
A meeting at the beginning of the cycle,...
...we also knew because again of research done by Bell Labs...
...that the highest performing teams were driven by daily meeting.
So, we knew we had to have the daily meeting.
But we wanted it to be a really short meeting...
...and we got it down to no more than 15 minutes.
And in that meeting, everybody on the team needs to know what everybody else has been doing,...
...what they're going to do next and how they can help one another move really fast.
So, it's like a huddle in a football game but a little bit longer than a huddle.